[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue surface au
territoire ici à tv5 monde en direct
comme chaque jeudi avec nos partenaires
co producteur de cette émission vous le
savez maintenant où ouest france.fr nous
diffuse en direct nicematin.com ou
diffusent en direct et puis
franceantilles.fr en léger décalage dû
aux différents fuseaux horaires ce sont
nos partenaires co producteur de cette
émission et ce matin je reçois sébastien
lecornu bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes ministre d outre mer une
question immédiatement lié à l'actualité
on apprit qu'assembler nationale allait
rétablir l'échéance du 31 juillet pour
le pass sanitaires est-ce que c'est
automatiquement toujours le cas pour les
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
français le principe c'est que c'est oui
et puis malheureusement parfois il nous
est arrivé dans la loi devoir adapter
les calendriers parce que la cinétique
comme on dit si bien de l'épidémie la
maison comporte le virus n'est pas la
même en fonction des territoires pour
des raisons climatiques pour des raisons
géographiques et désormais maintenant
depuis quelques semaines pour des
raisons qui tient aussi à une faible
taux de vaccination de faible couverture
vaccinale est donc le principe c'est que
les mesures de restriction ou de
freinage s'applique sur l'ensemble du
territoire l'exception c'est qu'elles
sont bien sûr module est un exemple
peut-être très concret en ce moment même
vous avez toujours la martinique et la
guyane qui font l'objet d'une vigilance
particulière parce que les taux
d'incidence on a plus de sens pour l'un
et à plus de 150 pour l'autre et notre
vigilance où nous venons de restituer le
port du masque pour un certain nombre de
de pratiquer à la réunion puisqu'on voit
bien que le taux d'incidence est repassé
au dessus des 50 donc malheureusement il
faut rester vigilant et puisque ne
permet peut-être de passer ce premier
message ça reste avant tout des hommes
en outre mer quand on regarde les
situations en service de réanimation
une épidémie de concitoyens et
concitoyennes non vaccinés est la
différence avec l'hexagone c'est
malheureusement cette protection
vaccinale sur lequel malheureusement
nous avançons trop trompés et ou en tout
cas trop lentement christiane taubira
vous a pas beaucoup aidé dans ce domaine
je l' ai connu parfois plus clair dans
ses propos après elle s'est repris sur
sur twitter enfin c'est pas la seule et
elle a pris la lumière ici à à paris
parce que c'était sur une une station de
radio un peu un peu connu mais oui une
partie des élites particulièrement aux
antilles ou en guyane ont eu du mal à
jouer ce rôle en répondant aux questions
légitimes signe de concitoyens sur le
vaccin c'est quoi un arn messagers etc
ouais me suis rendu en guyane ya quelque
temps on m'a dit mais ici à queue du
kaiser nous on aimerait une autre
technologie page c'est chose faite
depuis quinze jours et du janssen
disponible en guyane il faut se mettre à
la porte et aussi des questions qui nous
sont posées il faut le dire c'est quand
même le vaccin qui constitue la solution
on a parlé tout à l'heure avec cyril
bouty et notamment qui directeur des
rédactions du groupe france antilles qui
est avec nous sur ce plateau qui va nous
rejoindre dans un instant comment vous
faites pour enquiller les décalages
horaires et avoir l'air en forme comme
ça dès le matin votre secret je me suis
remis au sport ça aide un peu et puis il
en faut faire un petit peu attention une
forme d' hygiène de vie mais c'est
certain que c'est vrai que c'est un
petit matignon de le mystère des oui je
te dirai rien dire en tout cas si c'est
pour dire qu'on est intéressée à tous
les sujets qu'il se passe en outre-mer
balas et serait donc il faut être bon à
peu près en tout cas essayer d'être au
mauvais en rien vous enquillé combien de
2 km par an ah bah c'est la deuxième
fois en quatre mois que des chefs de
cabine air france me disent on a regardé
votre plan de vol vous avez volé plus
que nous cette année en faut dire aussi
qu'ils donnent un peu moins à cause du
que vides mais il est clair que le mois
dernier ce fut la guyane quelques jours
un retour à paris pour quelques jours
seulement puis un départ pour 15 jours
en nouvelle calédonie donc mais ça fait
partie du job et je pense important de
sida les incarner l'état au plus près
justement de nos concitoyens y compris
dans ce qu'ils sont les plus reculés de
dans l'arrêt publication prochaine je
présiderai les cérémonies du 11 novembre
avec annick girardin saint pierre et
miquelon c'est pas le territoire le plus
peuplé par fait rêver dans l'atlantique
nord et méritent aussi notre attention
très bien on va passer aux questions
territoriales maintenant françois xavier
le franc le rédac'chef de ouest france
nous rejoint sur ce plateau
[Musique]
notre invité ce matin sébastien lecornu
ministre d outre mer puisqu'il y en a
plusieurs bien sûr françois xavier le
franc on va tout de suite si vous le
voulez bien pour une fois regarder le
dessin de chaunu aujourd'hui c'est le
dessinateur humoriste de ouest-france
anormaux rose une question à normand
damien alors voilà qu'il faut une
question sous forme de dessin on écoute
on regarde monsieur le ministre l'heure
est grave non je ne vais pas vous parler
de votre beau département mais de la
crise des sous marins qui a fait de la
france la victime collatérale d'une
guerre menée par l'amérique et ses
alliés anglo saxons pour contrer
l'hégémonie chinoise alors la question
la question que je pose c'est
un premier puis un deuxième puis un
troisième je veux parler des référendum
sur l'avenir de la nouvelle calédonie ne
risque-t-il pas
d'affaiblir la france dans la zone
pacifique qui est devenu le nouvel
épicentre du monde
réponse de questions dans la question
ouais l'impact de cette affaire des sous
marins sur le pacifique si on a du temps
ça serait bien d'y revenir parce que je
pense que ça intéresse pas mal de nos
téléspectateurs puis à la question des
ce que c'est référendum affaiblissent la
position de la france moi je vous
réponds non déjà parce qu'ils ont été
prévues par l'accord de nouméa discuter
signé adoptée en 1998 et que plus on
s'approche de la fin de l'accord plus
celles et ceux qui l'ont parfois
négocier et signer puis ensuite voter
tout majorités politiques confondues ont
oublié ce qu'il y avait dedans et c'est
l'honneur de la france et c'est sa
puissance que de tenir parole pardon
mais nous avons des exemples de
colonisation puis de décolonisation qui
ne fout pas toujours qui ne furent pas
toujours heureux je crois dans notre
histoire on sait tous et il est vrai que
michel rocard
lionel jospin jacques chirac puis après
eux d'ailleurs à nicolas sarkozy
françois hollande et emmanuel macron ont
à coeur d'inscrire dans la permanence
française un processus extraordinaire
qui sort de toutes formes d'ordinaire
qui consiste à passer par les voies
démocratiques pour permettre à une
partie de la population d'être
dépositaire de la souveraineté de toute
la nation française pour décider si oui
ou non ce territoire de rexona
république et donc pardon mais faut il
répond très directement la démocratie ne
peut pas être un affaiblissement si des
pays de la zone pacifique
ne considère pas la démocratie comme
étant une valeur importante nous le
considérons et donc nous avons tenu
parole contrairement à ce que certains
candidats à l'élection présidentielle au
point toujours déclaré peuvent raconter
ce panel macron qui a choisi de faire
les trois référents alors se réfère
inscrit dans le marbre nous devons d
organiser ça se sont demandés ce
référendum le troisième tombe 2018 2020
2021 il aura lieu le 12 décembre les
élèves les indépendantistes ont dit
qu'ils ne participeraient pas donc quel
sens aura-t-il ce référendum puisque le
fn le fn ks n'y participent pas il faut
commencer par le début des ja
est ce qu'il aura vraiment lu lé 12
décembre la réponse est oui mais mais à
cause de collisions sanitaire valence
qu'il faut mettre les choses dans
l'ordre dans une démocratie on est aussi
de la méthode on ne joue pas comme ça
avec des décisions des élections être
sébastien le cours a doublé dans les dix
jours qui viennent la réalité c'est
qu'on regarde de près la situation
épidémique on voit que le taux
d'incidence s'installe dans une baisse
qui continue et désormais sur un taux
d'incidence à 125 surtout l'attention en
réa diminue m'attend faut regarder c'est
une incidence aussi géographiquement de
nouvelle calédonie donc dix jours très
très grand et donc il faut l'observer la
réalité surtout c'est que la vaccination
avance bien plus de 70% de la population
alors 12 d'être sur massa première 12
décembre et s'ils ont bien la 22° qu'ils
sont aujourd'hui c'est le 12 décembre
après enfin il faut pas qu'on raconte
non plus n'importe quoi à nos
téléspectateurs c'est pas la république
qui a voulu ce référendum c'est pas la
république qui veut l'indépendance en
revanche une partie de la population qui
fut colonisée c'est factuel considère
que l'émancipation et la période
post-coloniale passe par l'indépendance
et c'est pour cela que un système
démocratique a été imaginée qui permet
sur un corps électoral reste un de
trancher cette question ce fut deux fois
non les accords on prévoit un troisième
l'état lorsqu'il organise une
consultation qu'elle soit pour les
élections municipales en normandie ou en
bretagne ou pour une élection
référendaire est là pour garantir des
droits le droit de s'inscrire sur les
listes électorales le si on en a le
droit en fonction de la corse est une
particularité le droit d'établir des
procurations le droit d'aller en liberté
dans un bureau de vote mais il n'y a pas
d'obligation que leur campagne que
diriez vous que verriez-vous soyons
prêts siège à votre première question
pardonnez-moi mais la participation la
non participation est une appréciation
politique qui est naturel est libre dans
une démocratie en aucun cas à l'alter
est la sincérité du scrutin j'insiste
sur les indépendantistes qui n'ont
demandé au mois d'avril dernier ce
référendum que diriez vous le demande
nous l'organisons nous sommes tenus bien
que diriez vous aujourd'hui à les
habitants nouvelle calédonie notamment
des régions du nord qui peuvent penser
que avec la république le compte n'y est
pas que dit que leur diriez vous mais je
pense qu'il faut savoir l'entendre quand
ils le disent déjà pour commencer par ce
que il ya eu une promesse de réparation
qu'on a appelé le rééquilibrage vous
parlez du nord parce que l'accord de
nouméa dit toutes les richesses toutes
les opportunités d'emploi ne peuvent pas
être que dans nouméa pour faire très
vite là vaut sud et que donc et encore
il ya le nouméa et le sud voyez à
l'urbain et le rural entre guillemets et
c'est vrai que cette promesse de
rééquilibrage elle s'est faite avec
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent notamment sur
le nickel or aujourd'hui vous avez des
personnes qui malheureusement n'ont pas
un accès facile au marché de l'emploi
vous avez des inégalités fiscales et
sociales j'insiste sur fiscale et normes
financières énormes entre nouméa et le
reste de la population vous avez
malheureusement un taux d'illettrisme
d'illettrisme par manquer
particulièrement pourtant vous avez
parfois des tribus dans lequel il n'y a
pas d'eau potable en 2021 dans la
république française parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est la république
française vous avez des communes et des
tribus dans le cas il n'y a pas de
pottas donc il ya beaucoup à faire donc
il ya beaucoup à faire dans un pays
d'autonomie et ça ce sont des sujets que
je cherche à mettre sur la table parce
que quand il va avancer quand on parle
des territoires d'outre-mer selon que
l'on est en métropole ou dans les
territoires d'outre-mer on ne vit pas la
même chose une métropole on parle
souvent on en parle souvent quand à des
catastrophes ou on montre souvent une
vision de cartes postales et dans les
deux cas c'est souvent caricaturale
comment faire en sorte qu'on d avoir une
vision commune sur ces territoires sur
ce qu'est la france selon que l'on est
en en métropole ou en outre mer la
france et les diverses ces territoires
sont très diverses comme en février
cette vision commune ramet merci de la
question parce que c'est un une oeuvre
collective les politiques n'ont pas la
seule réponse mais il est clair que nos
outre-mer nous aurons tous les horizons
du monde je le dis à dessein ici sur tv5
monde mais de cela il faut en faire une
force déjà faut regarder le passé pour
ce qu'il est ce fut un passé colonial
avec derrière une promesse républicaine
qui permettait à chacun de trouver sa
place avec des droits des devoirs bref
on dit en deux phrases comment
aujourd'hui c'est aujourd'hui et c'est
unique ce sont des territoires qui nous
arrive à des continent tout entier
parlions tout à l'heure hors plateau de
la guyane qui a ri mais aussi continent
au continent sud américain et le
continent américain on parle de la
nouvelle calédonie dans le pacifique et
c'est la réalité c'est que effectivement
il faut sortir des caricatures et
d'ailleurs malheureusement les épisodes
de koh vider compris la question de la
vaccination a conduit à des caricatures
qui ont été blessantes particulièrement
blessantes pour nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens d'autres mères deux millions
six cent mille français d'outre-mer
exactement sans compter les familles qui
sont présents dans l'hexagone sans
compter celles et ceux qui ont choisi
d'aller travailler dans d'autres pays en
expatriation tous ses états c'est une
richesse absolument prodigieuse il ya
quand même des grands défis auxquels il
va falloir que l'on réponde et des
outre-mer peuvent d'ailleurs aidé
l'hexagone être en avance de phase c'est
évidemment la question de la transition
écologique mais quand j transition
écologique c'est le risque naturel et
environnemental
le plan de prévention des risques
naturels de saint martin va sortir on
est à la fin du quinquennat
rappelez-vous le début du quinquennat il
était marqué par rma et maria avec la
destruction en grande partie de saint
martin donc c'est outre mer ils sont en
en avant-poste meuf malheureusement pour
des risques mais ils le sont aussi pour
les solutions face à ces risques dont on
se serait bien avisé derrière érosion du
trait de côte je le dis pour
ouest-france bretagne normandie voilà ce
que l'on vit dans le pacifique peut être
une des solutions les territoires
l'examen ça se nourrit les territoires
ultramarins sont très dépendants des
importations les zones portuaires ont un
rôle évidemment très important une
question va vous être posée par
quelqu'un de guyane sur la sur la zone
du port de dégrad des cannes en grand
une grande zone portuaire je voulais
c'est pascal simon un de ouest france
qui a demandé à serge fulgence de vous
poser cette question sur ce port de
degrad de canon
l'actualité m'amène monsieur le ministre
à vous poser la question suivante s'il
arrive derrière
un problème au cours de la décade de
fois vivrons-nous en guyane quand on
indiquait le projet de développement
pour une autonomie
les importantes de l'alimentation du hub
port aéroport aussi enfin il faut il en
va en parler tout à l'aller 2 les deux
sont liés port fret marchandises mais
aussi fret hydrocarbures c'est compliqué
de répondre en deux minutes à la
question de monsieur mais il faut déjà
démarré aussi par une aberration c'est
la dépendance énergétique des
territoires d'outre-mer pourtant
intuitivement aux ide dans une île dans
un territoire comme la guyane on manque
pas de soleil on manque parfois pas de
vent on manque parfois pas d'énergies
marines ont peur ne manque pas de fleuve
on manque pas de bois et de se dire
qu'au fond en guyane c'est encore
essentiellement le pétrole qui permet le
fuel qui permet de produire son
électricité à quelque chose d'un tout
petit peu désuet alors on va continuer
parce que la transition doit être
progressive mais le fait de construire
cette centrale le larivot d'un projet
important guyane évacuent des réponses à
la transition et va donc aussi nous
permettre de soulager aussi à terme les
activités portuaires parce que la
centrale le larivot ce sera de la
biomasse d'abord d'importation et moi
j'en fais bleus eux arrivent à avoir une
biomasse bel et bien guyanaise et
française donc la question énergétique
est une des questions clés aux
interdépendance et aux dépendances après
il ya des enjeux importants mais comme
dans l'hexagone pardon sur les
productions agricoles on l'a vu à la
réunion où les confinements successifs
nous ont parfois fait prendre conscience
mais est ce que c'est vraiment bien
d'importer du surgelé parfois pas
toujours de bonne qualité qui
viendraient des quatre coins de la
planète tout l'hexagone alors qu'il ya
une potentialité fabuleuse en termes de
pêche en termes de production agricole
au delà des productions classiques
banane canne à swing et c'est donc là
aussi sur l'autonomie alimentaire il ya
un énorme chantier c'est un chantier qui
est créateur de richesses qui permettra
de faire diminuer les prix je pense
qu'on en reparlera mais la question de
la vie chère elle est évidemment
absolument essentiel elle permettra de
retracer des perspectives aussi à ses
ports qui pardon alors c'est mon dernier
propos j'essaie de faire vite parce que
c'est pas évident ce sujet en trois
minutes ne doivent pas être que des
ports d'importation mais devront être
aussi des ports d'exportation et ça
c'est un sujet absolument majeur guyane
le bois
le port de dégrad des cannes c'est
évidemment dans un sens mais c'est aussi
dans l'autre tous ministre d outre mer
avec des assises des économies et à six
les deux autres maires de l'économie des
outre-mer des assises qui sont
organisées avec le que ce blockbuster
maritime et le ministère d outre-mer
enfants pourraient dire des économies
des îles tonga parce qu'il ya tellement
il l'expliquait le ministre d'économie
différent bien évidemment territoires du
monde différent voilà
tous ces sujets là seront abordés lors
de ces assises un événement digital le 7
décembre prochain et cette année donc il
aura lieu maintenant chez chaque année
exactement et peuvent ce que vides il
prendra un regard particulier voilà
traduire cette france 7 décembre 2021 la
nouvelle france prune de ouest france
elle est évidemment consacrée à la crise
sanitaire mais elle est aussi consacrée
à la situation internationale la chine
n'est pas à la coop 26 d'ailleurs le
président chinois n'est pas sorti de son
pays depuis 2000 21 il n'a pas rencontré
depuis deux ans par dont il n'a pas
rencontré ses homologues depuis depuis
près de deux ans donc que fait la chine
c'est la grande question qui est
développé dans l'éditorial de ce matin à
la une de votre ancien d'ailleurs on
posera la question tout à l'heure au
ministre d outre-mer qui est notre
invité ce matin sébastien lecornu merci
françois xavier le franc rédacteur en
chef et ouest france premier quotidien
francophone du monde exactement merci
beaucoup on passe à cyril boutier
directeur des rédactions du groupe
france antilles notre partenaire dans un
instant
[Musique]
bonjour cyril bouttier d'abord merci
d'être avec nous spécialement mais aussi
parce que je me suis vous arrivez de
fort-de-france quand je vais arriver
hier soir hier en début de matinée voilà
donc vous demander au ministre les
outre-mer des conseils ou le bricolage
walter dans un instant on va passer à
vos questions mais tout de suite denis
carot directeur des rédactions du groupe
nice matin autres partenaires à une
question à vous poser par rapport à une
actualité tant en france et on va voir
ce que ça donne en outre père sébastien
lecornu bonjour la proposition de
yannick jadot d'interdire la chasse le
week end et pendant les vacances
scolaires fait beaucoup réagir les
chasseurs de nos territoires est ce
qu'on ne laisse pas trop de liberté aux
chasseurs en france et ne faudrait-il
pas encadrer davantage et réguler
davantage cette activité est alors
question corollaire peut-on expliquer à
des chasseurs en guyane que le week-end
on peut pas chasser en plus le système
de permis récents en guyane c'est une
pratique est un loisir qui est très
encadrée moi j'étais secrétaire d'état à
l'écologie et j'ai fait la réforme de la
chasse ne faut pas laisser à penser que
la chasse aujourd'hui n'est pas encadré
d'ailleurs le président de la fédération
nationale des chasseurs est le premier à
dire que s'il ya des brebis galeuses
parmi les chasseurs il faut les
sanctionner très vite pour pas que
l'ensemble du troupeau si j'ose dire
soit montrée à tort du doigt bon après
faut pas non plus qu'on tombe dans le
panneau monsieur jadot candidat à
l'élection présidentielle qui s'agitent
évidemment pour faire parler lui parce
qu'on ne peut pas dire que sa campagne
démarre très très bien moi j'aimerais
surtout savoir ce que les maires des
grandes communes
quand même de france qui sont dirigés
par des écologistes depuis un an et demi
ont fait c'est toujours la fuite en
avant quand ils sont pas contre tous nos
amis écologistes
en général ils font diversion pour aussi
ne pas regarder leur bilan de près alors
qu'ils sont aux manettes maintenant dans
des communes des métropoles dans lequel
il ya des moyens financiers bien qu'il
ya des compétences importantes côté
donné par le vol la république donc
qu'il réussisse la transition en matière
de déchets de 35 heures ont fait d'eau
d'assainissement d'énergie parce que ça
c'est un piquet si cette loi devait
passer en amazonie où c'est impossible
mais pas de l'oie d'ailleurs son propos
de monsieur jeannot et non mais si ça
vous appliquer ce que ça serait
applicable en amazonie c'est ça la
question non je sais bien mais en plus
une nouvelle calédonie aussi un rapport
à l'achat ce qui est très bien tant
qu'on retrouve d'ailleurs dans toute la
population donc une fois de plus faux il
faut aussi arrêter de stigmatiser les
cultures françaises voilà après ça veut
pas dire que c'est statu quo ça veut pas
dire que c'est la chasse n'importe
comment ça veut pas dire que la
biodiversité n'est pas à protéger quand
un oiseau particulier j'ai dû à
connaître de ces questions est en voie
de disparition bien faut savoir lever le
pied sur cette chasse ou l'interdire ça
c'est un autre débat mais la
stigmatisation d'une culture française
qui n'est pas propre à la france
d'ailleurs pour la chasse à quelque
chose aussi bizarres et la une de nice
matin qu'on regarde ensemble dans un
instant la voix la main tendue aux 16-25
ans ce sont les 500 euros versée en
contrepartie d'une formation qui sont à
la une de nice matin tout de suite elle
s'appellerait monde elle est chauffeuse
de bus depuis 40 ans à cayenne elle à
une question sur le coût de la vie là
bas on écoute
[Musique]
avec le séisme
le coût de la vie
et en guyane c'est facile partout c'est
vrai
monsieur le ministre pour rebondir sur
la question de cette dame
une des préoccupations pratiques
principal outre mer c'est le pouvoir
d'achat est particulièrement le prix des
carburants le prix des carburants qui a
augmenté encore au 1er novembre en
martinique en guadeloupe en guyane je
pense singulièrement la bouteille de gaz
qui a augmenté d'un euro d'un euro et 31
centimes après avoir augmenté de la même
façon le mois précédent on est
aujourd'hui une bouteille de gaz si qui
sur les douze derniers mois a augmenté à
peu près de 7 à 8 8 euros selon les
territoires
c'est très important évidemment pour les
populations quelle est la marge de
manoeuvre du gouvernement sur ces
questions sur la vie chère en général je
vais vous dire les hydrocarbures
évidemment c'est ce qui se voit tout de
suite et c'est un gros poste de dépense
qu'on a également les mêmes sujets sur
des produits de première nécessité et le
riz les pâtes à farine etc pour moi
c'est un chantier pour moi mal et entre
nous j'avais commencé à m'y atteler
avant d'avoir eu les pattes coupées par
la reprise de l'épidémie de e vide 19 au
moment où j'ai été nommé ministre d
outre mer mais mes prédécesseurs dans
des quinquennats précédent avait déjà
accompli des choses les boucliers de sur
les d pris fin il ya des choses déjà
qu'ils existent moi je pense qu'il faut
prendre le taureau par les cornes c'est
même un sujet de campagne présidentielle
si vous voulez vraiment faire ma pensée
et c'est un sujet qui doit pas attendre
début du prochain quinquennat quelles
que soient ses et ceux qui sortiront des
urnes 1 déjà il ya un enjeu de réflexion
sur la fiscalité je vous donne un
exemple que que très précise que m'avait
interpellé sur les carburants justement
personne banksy vaudrait bbc le cm et
justement intéressant personne ne sait
mais l'état ne perçoit plus depuis belle
lurette un euro un centime une queue de
mirabel une queue de cerise de fiscalité
sur les hydrocarbures
en outre même temps que le débat qui
nous a animés dans l'hexagone et ce
qu'il fallait un chèque
contre l'inflation pour aider les plus
fragiles à payer leur carburant ou est
ce qu'il fait les baisser les taxes à la
façon de la faire était déjà dite pour
les outre-mer parce que l'intégralité de
la fiscalité est perçue par les
collègues que vous n'aviez vitoria ge de
manoeuvre vous ah bah je ne peux pas
décider de diminuer l'octroi de mer
parce qu'il s'agit de cela je pense dès
lors que ce n'est pas l'état qui perçoit
cet octroi de mer ça c'est le chèque
énergie a été faire le chèque
anti-inflation a été imaginée parce
qu'il permet aux personnes les plus
fragiles ceux ci madame touchent moins
de 1000 euros par mois pour le coup elle
y sera et gilly éligibles et elle a
parlé du cng le centre spatial guyanais
donc ça veut dire bien dire aussi qu
homme qui a des bonnes nouvelles en
matière de développement et d'emplois en
guyane on y reviendra peut-être sur le
spatial en tout cas moi c'est un sujet
sur lequel il faut avancer ça pose la
question pendant des plombs mais ça pose
la question sur la lutte contre les
monopoles avoir le choix avoir le choix
de là on achète nourriture là on achète
sa voiture ça c'est un enjeu absolument
majeur qu'il ya des enjeux sur le fret
peut-être qu'on est malheureux à toute
allure mais mais je pense que là c'est
un chantier transversale mais faut pas
se payer de mots derrière ceci toute une
économie parfois insulaire ancien fruits
de l'héritage parfois dû passer ça
voulait dire et aux éditions culturel
aussi ouais pas que culturelles
économiques de dépendances on parlait
tout à l'heure d'autosuffisance c'est
sûr quand on consomme un produit local
il peut te moins cher que lorsqu'il
vient d'une autre bout de la planète
c'est une transformation économique
profonde et moi je suis prêt parce que
je pense que c'est un sujet absolument
clé d'émancipation et surtout qui
permettra de réduire les coûts le coût
de la vie mais un global sébastien
lecornu l'autre actualité aux antilles
vous l'avez évoqué tout à l'heure et en
guyane c'est la crise sanitaire mais
c'est surtout le refus de l'obligation
vaccinale chez les soignants notamment
les mobilisations succèdent en
martinique en guadeloupe
hier l'hôpital de kourou en guyane
étaient bloqués on sent qu'il ya un
dialogue qui a du mal à reprendre à
l'image de la dé la médiation que vous
avez envoyé avec olivier ferrand en
martinique qui n'a pas vraiment débuté
hier comme elles auraient dû débuter
est-ce qu'il va falloir adapter la loi
sur l'obligation vaccinale
non enfin la loi c'est la loi la
république pour tous puis une obligation
morale se protéger quand sa mission par
ailleurs et de protéger celles et ceux
qui sont qui sont malades donc moi je
les ai toujours indiquer le bon sens de
l'emporter après nous ne céderons pas
face aussi des minorités qui clairement
sont dans une forme désormais
d'agitation politique oui je le dis pour
la première fois en six ans de la tour
j'ai jamais dis ça depuis le début mais
l'accueil qui a été réservé hier à la
mission de médiation témoignent d'une
forme de mauvaise foi soyons bien clair
que des gens disent j'ai un doute sur le
vaccin c'est complètement normal il faut
rester très très très calme là dessus
moi je suis pas médecin donc voilà que
des soignants disent eux mêmes nous
refusera se faire vacciner bon ensuite
d'essayer en dise on refusera de se
faire vacciner même si c'est obligatoire
alors déjà dans un schéma où il son
pardon mes fonctionnaires ils sont donc
dépositaires au site ce qu'est la
puissance publique alors le service
public rendu service public hospitalier
c'est pas une petite mission est
derrière nous avec olivier ferrand nous
sommes plutôt magnanime patients
allaient coûter en tout cas je le prends
lettre nous envoyons une médiation
composée de personnalités qui sont
robustes qui sont reconnus et ces
personnes sont mal accueillies on va là
où désormais le masque tombe bien moi je
pense qu'il faut séparer les personnes
qui ont de vraies questions sur la
vaccination qui se posent des questions
légitimes qui peut avoir peur qui peut
avoir des questions sur la technique
même de la rn message à tous l es le
bienvenu en revanche les personnes qui
se servent de ça pour agiter un conflit
de nature politique au social je pense
qu'il faut pas prendre la santé des
martiniquaises ou des martiniquais et
des guadeloupéens ou d'aiguillonner
effectivement en otage parce que pendant
ce temps là le taux d'incidence lui ineo
et le nombre de personnes ne présentant
réa est toujours bel et bien élevé donc
vous prenez très au sérieux ce risque
entre guillemets d'embrasement social et
qui pourrait faire tache d'huile dans
d'autres secteurs que celui de la santé
oui fait en invitant tous les dans tous
les départements non étoiles dans leur
nom c'est ce qui est terrible aussi
parce que ça conduit une stigmatisation
des antilles et de la caraïbe ou de la
guyane fins et ce ne sont pas les outre
mer ce sont quelques territoires
d'outre-mer et c'est terrible parce que
je vous dise que j'ai sur le coeur
donc c'est qu'en fait on va avoir on a
une reprise épidémique vous le voyez
dans l'hexagone mais comme la couverture
l'exception antique est ce que vous
sentez river north même mieux que ça ou
pire que ça plutôt c'est que on va avoir
un monde qui va commencer à revivre
normalement après que vide grâce à la
vaccination mais les états unis voyez
ouvre progressivement
enfin c'est un retour à une forme de vie
normale qui sera pas celle qu'on a
connue avant que enfin on va avoir
quelque chose liberté vous en dis là est
donc les libertés aussi d'entreprendre
de reprendre une économie de souffle et
on va avoir quelques territoire dans
lequel
malheureusement on a un retard c'est
comme ça mais surtout ce retard va
s'installer pour de mauvaises raisons et
ça c'est préoccupant parce que vous me
posez la question est-ce que je crains
d'autres embrasement nom de l'autre côté
vous avez une vraie pression par exemple
du monde touristique vous les connaissez
bien sûr qu'ils le disent maintenant on
veut reprendre on veut le pass on veut
que noël sont pas une saison perdue
parce que c'est un moment important dans
la vie déjà de tout à chacun doit elle
manque aussi en matière touristique donc
en fait il ya une énergie terrible est
formidable positive de reprise d'une vie
normale elle est très forte part d'un
pas des compagnies aériennes enfin vous
avez des compagnies gazières énorme des
secteurs énorme pour la richesse des
antilles et de l'autre côté vous avez
une minorité qui effectivement se crispe
sur cette question de la vaccination
parfois pour de bonnes raisons faut le
respecter mais aussi malheureusement on
le voit bien pour le mauvaise c'est
sébastien lecornu ministres des autres
vercken autres invités politiques ce
matin en face aux territoires une
émission coproduite par ouest france
nice matin il france senti tout de suite
nice matin a rencontré philippe
chevallier c'est sébastien botella qu'il
a rencontrés il est président de cette
cargo international à marseille il à une
question posée par rapport au premier
plan de relance monsieur le ministre on
écoute nous sommes transitaires super
series et est implantée sur les outre
mer
ma question est simple
quelle est la part du frêne réservé dans
le plan de relance sur les outre mer
vous le savez monsieur le ministre nous
sommes confrontés aujourd'hui et depuis
déjà quelques temps à une sous capacité
opérationnelle sur ces destinations
le plan de relance va être présent
l'activité reprend la capacité n'est pas
là
avez vous par exemple prévu leur mettre
en place des vols cargo sur certaines
destinations comme nous en avons connus
sur la réunion il ya quelques années
très concrète questions directes pour ce
direct ont déjà la relance et la relance
de l'économie tout entière et donc si la
relance de la demande vous voyez notre
croissance européenne y compris nos
territoires d'outre-mer elle est très
importante et si elle relance par la
demande il ya donc aussi une relance par
définition des besoins offre est la
deuxième des choses c'est que les aides
au fret ne sont pas dans le plan de
relance que sont dans le budget de mon
ministère répond très directement la
question je souhaite qu'on puisse les
revoir ses aides au fret les adapter les
peut-être les mettre à jour parce
qu'elles datent aussi un tout petit peu
avec un système évidemment j'ai beaucoup
évolué troisième chose me faut aussi
regarder le travail de monsieur qui
m'interrogent un travail important parce
que c'est lui qui fait la mise en
relation entre 7 et ceux qui vont
transporter cg ce qu'ils ont produit
pour faire très très vite bon ben là il
ya un enjeu de dialogue cma-cgm on vient
de voir là la photo s'affiche et qui a
pris des responsabilités importantes
parce qu'ils ont fixé leurs prix ils ont
rétabli typiquement pour la réunion il y
avait un doute sur un deuxième circuit
de fret et il a bien été maintenue enfin
on va bien sic et les compagnies
aériennes donc qui ont été largement
soutenues dans le cadre du plan de
relance et dans le cadre du poids qu'il
en coûte sur lequel on voit bien que les
billets d'avion parfois diminue pour les
passagers mais ça augmente pour le fret
bomba ce sont des sujets sur lequel il
faut discuter avec eux tout cas moi je
suis disponible avec jemâa 6 et javari
l'ensemble des autres ministres annick
girardin aussi à travailler sur ce sujet
mais il faut aussi qu'on arrive à avoir
des réponses de long terme c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure que certaines
denrées alimentaires viennent de
l'hexagone pour à la réunion pardon
pour finir sur une note positive
monsieur positive monsieur le ministre
les outre-mer sont aussi un atout pour
la france je pense à l'espace maritime
heureusement à la biodiversité alarme à
col v en guyane
chasse humaine aussi déjà tout
simplement des personnes qui y vivent
mais vous avez raison sur les questions
environnementales
je disais tout à l'heure sur le risque
naturel et sur la transition énergétique
sur la biodiversité le problème c'est
que ça fait dix ans aussi qu'on le dit
comme un slogan est que derrière parfois
ça ne se traduit pas forcément mais on a
eu c'est pour ça qu'on plan de relance
chris hani payet se lance à l'entreprise
on a recherché les vaccins partout dans
le monde extérieur on sait par exemple
qu'en guyane sur la canopée les
médicaments de demain s'invente là bas
se trouve là bas pourquoi on ne le dit
pas assez pour quoi vous le ministre des
mines en parlant là ces a été dit
beaucoup s'en suivre forcément que ce
suivi d'effet pendant des années et
qu'aujourd'hui l'aiguillé zélés guyane
et quand on leur fait le coup de faux
pas toucher à votre biodiversité parce
qu'un jour le créa la richesse et de
l'emploi les gens vous regardent en
lisant ouais on ne savait 20 ans qu'on
nous le dit mais c'est vrai que pour la
première fois depuis maintenant deux ans
j'ai pu les rencontrer grâce au plan de
relance il ya des vraies entreprises
locales qui sont en train de se
structurer et conquérir des parts de
marché après à un jeu de patience parce
que principe de l'innovation c'est un
peu lève toi et marche c'est à dire que
faut essayer des choses et puis ensuite
trouvé son marché mais ça va ça va être
le cas notamment aussi sur la des
produits de beauté on voit bien que le
la relation désormais aux produits de
cosmétique est différente sur l'impact
environnemental sur les pollutions sur
éventuellement les prélèvements qui sont
faits sur les animaux pour tous ces
sujets l'endroit j'ai produit de beauté
en guyane typiquement là aussi à une
forêt amazonienne est quelque chose
d'assez formé de la hutte de des
pressentis bouttier
la une de france antilles la consigne du
pass sanitaire voilà elle est très liée
à la crise sanitaire et au difficile
début de la médiation que nous avons
évoqué tout à l'heure mais le passé est
un outil d'un top 10 pendant des
libertés je le dis parce qu'il nous est
demandé par les acteurs économiques en
outre mer merci cyril bouty d'être venue
de fort de france pour interviewer ça
sébastien lecornu ce matin dans cette
émission face aux territoires dont
france antilles et partenaires tout de
suite dé m korkmaz de tv5monde nous
rejoint sur ce plateau
[Musique]
avec sébastien le corps du ministre d
outre-mer et des questions
internationales s'il en est avec la
chine oui la chine et la
nouvelle-calédonie est ce que le 12
décembre prochain le référendum ne va
pas plutôt se transformer pour les
qualifs de lien entre un choix entre la
france et la chine non ce serait trop
rapide de dire cela je sais pas moi qui
le dit hein cjm l'institut de recherche
stratégique de l'école militaire vous
savez on parle d'une situation plus
personne ne regardait ce qui se passait
dans cette partie du monde à une
situation où désormais on aimerait
mettre un tout de suite un drapeau
chinois sur la nouvelle calédonie non il
ya risque selon vous un entrisme chinois
très fort mais reste sur gérance
toujours existé après ce qu ils sont
plus nombreux aujourd'hui qui nourrit
dans les années 80 la réponse est oui
pour une simple et bonne raison c'est
que lorsque les accords de matignon dino
été signé en 1988 même la guerre froide
se désintéresser très peu du pacifique
sud le président fusent
les accords de nouméa en 1998 vous avez
pratiquement aucune pression
internationale si ce n'est pas une usine
classique conventionnelle lui il y en a
aujourd'hui il ya effectivement des des
grandes puissances russie etats unis et
chine on l'a vu avec eux la sphère dit
au cul des sous-marins qu'effectivement
se disputent une part d' influence
importante dans le pacifique nord non
sans écho est conséquent sur le
pacifique sud mais aujourd'hui il faut
pas raconter d'histoires c'est la france
regardez les les zones de pêche dans le
pacifique vous regardez les images
satellites vous avez des bateaux de
pêche par tous y compris des bateaux de
pêche chinois vous avez d énorme tâche
bleue immaculé préserver c'est la zone
économique exclusive française
polynésienne wallisienne et calédonie
pardonnez moi je reviens à ce rapport de
l'irsn qui est vraiment très alarmiste
et qui dit concrètement la chine fait de
l'entrisme et particulièrement auprès
des élus indépendantistes des mouvements
indépendantistes au travers de deux
d'amicale ou d'associations si nos wii
s'est exilé ionienne moi je connais bien
indépendantistes pour être quand même le
négociateur et est passé beaucoup de
temps avec avec eux beaucoup si vous
dise avec beaucoup de sérieux que ils ne
veulent pas régler un problème des
colonials ou coloniales avec la
république française pour aller se
mettre dans les mains d'une nouvelle
route de la soie qui pourrait les
asservir je vous donne un exemple très
précis en cas d'indépendance quelles
seraient les traités commerciaux de
kanaky l'état nouvellement indépendants
est-ce que c'est toujours des traités
commerciaux européens ce qui permet donc
d'avoir une négociation douanière avec
la chine notamment pour les 70% nickel
qui quitte la nouvelle calédonie pour
allez enchaîner aussi véhicules des
traités des traités commerciaux qui sont
à renégocier par le nouvel état avec la
république populaire de chine ce qui
fait que la chine pourrait décider
d'adopter une barrière douanière à
l'entrée ça ce sont des questions
désormais très concrète au delà même des
ingérences qui sont aussi des questions
de positionnement la nouvelle calédonie
qu'elle reste française ou qu'elle
devienne indépendante dans cette partie
du s que alors vous vouliez parler aussi
de l'australie puisque cette référendum
en nouvelle calédonie a des
répercussions bien au-delà du territoire
est-ce que ce référendum n'a pas aussi
un peu sonné le système d'alarmé de
l'australie qui s'est dit oh là là
attention la france n'est pas capable de
tenir son territoire un territoire qui
pourrait lui échapper avec ce troisième
référendum donc ce n'est plus un allié
crédible non on ne croit pas déjà en
passage pardon de le dire comme je le
pense mais la nouvelle calédonie c'est
d'abord une affaire de français entre
français y compris pour les
indépendantistes qui aujourd'hui sont
français donc on peut pas parler
d'ingérence chinoise et puis
m'interroger en déplorant une
non-ingérence ou une ingérence
australienne je pense qu'il faut qu'on
se le dise c'est une affaire aussi entre
français après est-ce que la situation
est tendue dans le pacifique est-ce
qu'elle sera de plus en plus la réponse
est oui d'ailleurs les canadiennes et
les canadiens s'y sont pas trompés sur
la sphère des sous marins ils n'ont pas
forcément vu une perte d influence
française illusion aussi vu ou peut être
vue le fait qu'un grand pays voisin a
décidé initialement d'avoir une sous
marinade à propulsion électrique diesel
et au final finissent de l'abandonner
c'était la solution française pour une
propulsion nucléaire ça dit quelque
chose aussi
de la zone en tension y compris sur le
terrain militaire et les calédoniens
dans un pacific très grand
majoritairement même les
indépendantistes comment ceux-ci avoir 7
malheureusement cette perspective de
malheur au petit dans un moment qui sera
par définition très tendues avec les
grands quelle est la nouvelle option de
la france en dans cette région du monde
alors qu'est ce que vous entendez par
une nouvelle option parce que ça veut
dire quoi nouvelle alliance a mais de
toutes les évidences enfin moi je suis
gaulliste et donc que j'aime bien rester
aussi sur les fondamentaux de ce qu'a
été la diplomatie du général de gaulle
jusqu'aujourd'hui enfin il faut pas non
plus qu'on présente la chine comme un
pays adversaires c'est un pays
partenaire sur lequel nous sommes un peu
plus de vigilance je rappelle que c'est
général de gaulle qui a reconnu pékin et
ça c'est aussi de la pub spécificité
française il faut leur expliquer aussi à
nos concitoyens nous les etats unis le
monde évidemment occidentales font
partie de nos à d'historique par les
australiens je suis normand ils ont
largement participé à la libération de
la normandie ne faut pas qu'on commence
à raconter n'importe quoi et l'australie
et le gouvernement de monsieur morrison
je pense qu'on peut distinguer un peu
les choses mais pareil il faut que notre
france je pense que présente à un public
raison de le faire comme il le fait on
doit garder cette voie singulière dans
le pacifique je veux pas dire non
alignés mais pas loin mais singulière au
risque de disparaître non contraire au
risque de perdurer c'est ça la france au
fonds restants le ps regardez regardez
les propos du général de gaulle sur sur
cette partie du monde regardez le lait
les bouquins d'alain peyrefitte sur ces
sujets il ya une permanence français sur
ces questions françois mitterrand l'a
entretenue emmanuel macron aujourd'hui
le leur à fils sébastien lecornu on
reste dans le pacifique bon il ya les
jeux de paris et jeux olympiques un 2024
alors les jeux de comptes appelle les
jeux de paris mais l'épreuve de surf
aura lieu à tahiti et oui les études
alors une magnifique vague qui s'appelle
tshopo la vague de zschopau 5 m 48
surfer vont se disputer cette vague que
je crois que vous avez l'intention d'y
aller ou le dira suffisait les allées on
la voit derrière vous theunis tanguay
vaille elle est bientôt y est allé
elle est absolument magnifique alors il
ya il ya eu une petite controverse sur
place en disant que les infrastructures
qui devait être aménagé vont sans doute
peut-être rendre le lieu un peu moins
agréable qu'il n'est aujourd'hui est ce
que c'est vrai tout ça est ce qu'on
souhaite y c'est edouard fritch le
président du pays aussi qui est
largement compétent sur ce sujet mais il
a à coeur comme moi de ne pouvoir
accueillir cette épreuve mais de le
faire de manière complètement
responsables sur le terrain écologique
parce que le temps des jo dans lequel le
rouleau compresseur arrive seule la
beauté des images compte l'audimat et
derrière on saccage tout et on laisse
des infrastructures en plan pour les
populations heureusement ce monde a
changé et un alignement de planètes
distinguer le président la république la
maire de paris également parce que à la
une part importante aussi à jouer dans
cette affaire donc voilà hélas le pays
là bas a fait ce qu'il fallait pour
qu'on soit capable pas la crise sur les
épreuves de sarir sur une épreuve de
surf comme celles ci n'ont sera le faire
et au contraire je pense que c'est un
bon moyen de meilleure série française
vous parliez d'ailleurs des atouts à des
départements et territoires d'outre-mer
français là et je te parie et pourtant
ça se passe à tahiti mais ça se passera
des milliers et des milliers de
kilomètres de paris mais ça c'est le
magazine de référence du sang france est
dirigée par jean grâce aux cessions qui
nous a fourni ces informations et ces
magnifiques images en provenance de
tahiti sur six est ok la mecque
polynésiens parce qu'il ya des surfeurs
polynésiens qui en plus peut être ronde
et des perspectives de chances de
médaille le prochain directeur de
campagne emmanuel macron présidentielle
oufa sébastien lecornu vous n'êtes pas
pour le 10ème journalistes me reposer et
vous allez ce matin nous répondent oui
formidable et non pas cédant le pas ce
que parce que c'est pas comme ça que ça
fonctionne parce que pour le coup il est
présent dans la république il n'est pas
candidat c'est à lui de répondre à la
question est ce qu'il sera candidat ou
non après si votre question c'est de
dire est ce que j'ai envie de militer il
devait être candidat bah oui parce que
c'est normal quand on est ministre déjà
de défendre le bilan qui est le nôtre
parce qu'on n'a pas eu que la chance et
j'ose dire crise et gilet jaune et
qu'est-ce que vide et donc on a quand
même mieux de tout ça fait des réformes
et faire avancer le pays donc ça c'est
bien normal quand on est ministre
pratiquement tout le quinquennat comme
moi de répondre à cet enjeu là et puis
ensuite quand je regarde les autres
candidats et que j'aime mon pays mais je
me dis que oui ça serait peut-être une
bonne chose qui me donne maintenant soit
de nouveau candidat après qu'est ce que
vous souhaiteriez faire qu'est ce que
vous aimeriez faire presser ministère
l'autre mais être heureux oui tout un
programme tout un programme donc je suis
heureux dans ce que je fais aujourd'hui
parce que j'ai le sentiment de beaucoup
de données pour la nouvelle calédonie
les autres territoires aussi mais tout
le monde comprendra bien qu'en ce moment
le dossier dans un moment complexe
singulier et aussi eu des moments très
forts avec les indépendantistes sur le
terrain personnel des idées et ce serait
quoi prenant le mystère idéal ses
ministres dans lequel vous êtes utile
avec une mission on peut être ministre
de quelque chose de prestigieux s'il ya
rien à y faire quand on a 35 ans est un
mouroir donc dit non mais faut se dire
les choses ce qui est intéressant c'est
est ce qu'internet à l'écologie bur
notre dame des landes fessenheim la
réforme de la chasse j'étais mise des
collectivités locales j'ai organisé le
grand débat national pendant la crise et
gilet jaune j'en trouve mise d outre mer
j'ai la nouvelle calédonie des enjeux de
gestion ducobu qui sont terribles c'est
le plan de charge cette plan de bataille
qui fait la magie jobs merci sébastien
lecornu alchimie entre des outre-mer
d'être venu sur le plateau de tv5monde
une première pour vous et oui car dans
ces monuments merci beaucoup merci des
maîtres korkmaz face aux territoires sur
tv5 monde bien sûr en repli samedi matin
et puis ouest france.fr nicematin.com et
franceantilles.fr vont bien sûr
rediffusé cette émission merci au revoir
à tous à jeudi prochain les programmes
continus sur tv5
[Musique]